tom brokaw the longtime news anchor who
named world war ii veterans the greatest
generation now faces accusations of
sexual misconduct former NBC News
correspondent Linda Wester tells The
Washington Post that Brokaw tried to
forcibly kiss her in the 1990s another
woman claims Brokaw forced her to touch
his chest
Brokaw who's 78 denies the claims he's
the latest high-profile media figure
accused of inappropriate behavior after
the firing of Charlie Rose by CBS News
and NBC's firing of Matt Lauer who also
faces new accusations and a Warner is
here with the newest report and a good
morning good morning Nora The Post spoke
with 12 current and former NBC staffers
who claim they experienced sexual
harassment over the past 25 years but
did not report it
Wester says NBC's failure to hire an
outside investigator after Lauer's
actions first came to light is what
prompted her to step forward I was
groped and assaulted by Tom Brokaw in
interviews with Variety magazine in the
Washington Post former NBC News
correspondent Linda Wester describes
what she claims were two unwanted
advances with Tom Brokaw in the
mid-1990s including one in which he
invited himself into her hotel room he
leans over with his index finger and
puts it on my mouth just silenced me and
says this is our compact and at that
point he took the same hand reach behind
my head and tried to force me to kiss
him
Brokaw said he met with fester twice at
her request and made no romantic
overtures toward her back then had she
reported something like this I don't
think anyone would have blinked
Washington Post journalist Sarah Ellison
reports around the same time a second
unnamed NBC employee claims Brokaw put
her hands against his chest and invited
her into his office Brokaw told the
paper no such incident happened neither
woman reported the allegations back then
they don't come forward for two very
good reasons one they're afraid they
won't be believed and two they're afraid
that they will face retaliation the post
also uncovered two
new allegations against Matt Lauer one
accuser claims the former Today Show
host exposed himself and asked her to
touch him a second claims he had sex
with her in the middle of the day in his
office and for the first time former
co-host Ann Curry revealed she warned
management about his behavior in 2012
something she stopped short of
acknowledging when she spoke with CBS
this morning in January I am NOT
surprised by the allegations we reached
out to Matt Lauer in NBC but did not
hear back NBC did tell The Washington
Post that it has no record of Curry's
warning Matt Lauer also admitted to the
post that he acted inappropriately but
says any allegations or reports of
korsak coercive aggressive or abusive
actions on my part at any time our
absolutely false Tom Brokaw refused our
request for comment he remains an NBC
News special correspondent yeah all
right thank you very much Anna